suite aux dégâts l'attaché de presse oui
mais il échoue venir avec lui aussi
intervenir à dominer
voilà
cauchon
messieurs comment ça va bien
il est prêt pour la promo la malle à mal
pas mal à répéter cela va répéter un peu
la promo au départ dany boon cette
histoire de travaux est inspiré d'une
histoire vécue
oui l'histoire des moulures par exemple
hélas la baguette entre autres c'était
un appartement genre haussmannien un
joli avec des belles moulures et
l'architecte voit une baguette de
téléphone en plastique et voilà il dit
il prend un de ces gars et il dit tu me
motive non 1,10 par lasser et de gagny
buzz comme ça j'aurais dû me méfier le
fait bien et et puis voilà et donc on
part voir le truc parler de plan les
machins trucs et on revient un quart
d'heure après il avait enlevé toutes les
moulures sauf la dette grecque
s'il croyait que la baguette était plus
moderne en plastique donc il se disait
ça faut que ça reste elle est bien allé
bien il avait fait un petit tas il avait
fait un petit tas avec on aurait dit
qu'il allait faire un petit feu de camp
et j'ai dit les moulures les moulures ça
il m'a dit ah ça va vous frappez pas
gelé remettent et les arts mine un peu
de travers il ya aussi la peinture dans
le sanitaire la peinture dans le
sanitaire c'est quand il a émis la
peinture danse et l'itf ça est bouché le
sanitaire oui ça c'est récent ça oui
c'est le félon vas voir c'est assez
récent c'est il ya trois semaines à la
campagne
le nom il avait vidé oui de la peinture
qui a séché dans un coup de l'évacuation
de toilette et donc quelqu'un nous
inviter à tirer la chasse d'eau et au
lieu de la fracture il appelle au dos
l'autre côté et on était dans l'embarras
et ça a fait le long des murs comme ça
et donc non ils ont été révision du tout
casser et ont pour faire les coudes tous
les coudes
je n'ai pas en quoi c'est dany boon oui
et non ça c'est la question une question
qu'on va te poser beaucoup dans la
promotion vous êtes un angoissé dany
boon est ce que vous étiez angoisses et
derrière la caméra
non j'étais pas gt non j'étais ça allait
non j'étais pas trop angoissé non j'ai
beau j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le film
en préparation justement pour pour pas
l'être dany boon vous préférez devant ou
derrière
peut-être me posais la question réelle
que tu meures spécialement de référence
est beaucoup plus confortable d'être
devant oui que derrière voilà on va lui
demander sur votre passé de storyboarder
et de photographes vous a aidé mais
c'est tout à fait vrai thierry je vois
que vous êtes bien renseigné et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous fait
licencier un quart d'heure votre
émission et je trouve ça complètement
quand oui j'étais dessinateur et
gt2 et storyboarder donc effectivement
j'ai appris à découper une histoire en
plan que cent pensent en outre il a
beaucoup bossé il a beaucoup bossé sur
ce fil des bosses des groupes de 5
heures du matin à minuit tu te rien si
kia ray dont j'aimerais énormément là on
prépare la promo là il ya un truc super
drôle sur le tournage je peux raconter
une anecdote chose que tu veux en
escrime pour une décès de la noce 2006
--et patrick c'est une beau temps wesley
encore au moins une année
la maison qu'on détruit qu'on a remis en
état d'ailleurs pas avec la même équipe
la maison qu'on a des trucs se trouve à
maisons laffitte et donc au début on n'a
pas eu les autorisations de tournage
s'est scindé le député maire de maisons
laffitte
chaque milliard pour la non non non ce
milliard mais je garde aussi la ouais
bon bref nous nous donnons pas les
autorisations et grâce à claude berri on
les obtient il nous dit il est dit et il
fait à la production il y voit les
cheveux rencontré dany boon ont tourné
pendant un mois la balle il jouait je
veux rencontrer d'un niveau de jeu dit
non maintenant je travaille j'ai pas le
temps ça ça m'intéresse pas et puis non
non non non et la production de 10
insiste en disant ça serait mieux qu'ils
viennent parce qu'il a finalement
accepté qu'on tourne dans sa ville c'est
vrai c'est sympa et puis voilà il a qu'à
venir pendant l'heure du déjeuner ça
dure une heure et après voilà je suis
déjà avec lynne il est très sympathique
et items beaucoup bon j d'accord donc il
arrive juste en train de travailler
vraiment du bonjour monsieur myard voilà
je termine puis on dit voilà des pauses
déjeuner on va à la cantine est sur le
chemin de la cantine il se tourne vers
moi qui me fait vous fait quoi sur le
sur le film gdba chèche lecteurs j'ai
écrite ça et je réalise ce niveau vous
produisez aussi le badge du produit
enfin un conte production mais comme
vous comme moteur méprendre mais oui
pourquoi il dit vous êtes claude berri
te jure que c'est vrai non je suis ni
semoun
allez je me dis je suis elie semoun il
me fait
mais oui pardon il y excusez moi eh bien
il me dit ça va pas fort en ce moment et
que dieudonné
je dis oui on sait c'est pareil on a un
peu des soucis va faire de la politique
comme vous c'est moi c'est la nature et
on marchand d'or une part je lui parle à
elie semoun depuis un moment il fait
mais il est où dany boon est vidé mais
je vous le présenter et je vois laurent
gamelon donc oui qui fait d'omettre que
halak et lounge fedeli député maire
jacques menut jeudi discrètement que je
suis au lycée moon qu'il est dany boon
ça et il fait au menu bonne je vous
adore depuis longtemps bravo tout ce que
vous faites il lui dit à lui sur ce je
pense à zinedine soualem qui est dans le
film mais je vais vous connaissez smaïn
à table avec une grande partie du show
business français une personne ne
correspondait la bonne personne de là il
y avait juste sa secrétaire qui veulent
assise à côté de moi qui quittent était
morte de trouille qui me disait dans
l'oreille bon dominique ça va la promo
nom va bien j'ai pas sur les planches
est ce qu'on pourrait dire de plus sur
le trampoline qui est toujours sous
tranquillisants je rassure il revient le
cas du jour dominique appliquer chez moi
je par contre chez inquiet pour l'avenir
alors qu'est ce qu'on va devenir bah oui
c'est bien moi
quand c'est pas grave mais là nos fils
nos spectacles qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va tous se donner la mort
alors dany vous êtes quand même un
acteur maintenant assez reconnus parce
que dans ce joyeux noël c'est formidable
s'est nommé aux césar ensuite il la
doublure de webber avec gad elmaleh
bientôt mon meilleur ami de patrice
leconte avec daniel auteuil ça ça
commence à exister un oui oui c'est
d'ailleurs la chance de tourner avec
avec patrice leconte est de donner la
réplique à daniel auteuil pendant trois
mois c'était s'était formée avant un
très beau rôle en plus un très très beau
film gelé les enfants ciel
bybee direct il n'est pas bien vraiment